31 million people and counting have been
fully vaccinated in america and we are
now getting some new guidelines from the
cdc on how to ease back
into normal life so here they are if
you've been fully vaccinated you can
gather in small groups
indoors without wearing a mask or social
distancing
and that includes gathering with on
vaccinated people as long as they are
low risk
and from the same household so big
question about travel
don't do it according to the cdc unless
it is essential they say
no to any non-essential travel as for
gathering in public spaces the cd says
cdc says
you should still wear a mask and social
distance in public
whether you're vaccinated or not now
keep in mind the definition of
vaccinated you are considered fully
vaccinated
two weeks after your second dose of a
two shot vaccine
or two weeks after a single dose of the
johnson
and johnson vaccine for more on all of
this we are joined now by dr david agus
uh dr aegis good morning to you
exactly who i'd want to see this morning
on a subject like this it's a big day
one year into the pandemic we're now
opening up a bit according to the cdc
what more do you think people need to
know
thank you tony um the important thing
this is data driven
based on data from the united kingdom in
israel what we know is that when you're
vaccinated and you're exposed to the
virus
there's very little chance of having
significant virus 70
will have no virus at all 30 percent
will be asymptomatic or mildly
symptomatic with a little bit of virus
and what that means is
you can get together safely with other
people who are vaccinated
and with one other family without chance
of significant viral spread
this is a major step forward one of many
that are going to have to happen
to get out of this pandemic why the
continued
no recommendation on medium to large
size gatherings and
travel if the vaccines are so effective
well we're learning more literally as we
go i think you're going to see more
relaxations over the next couple of
weeks
but what we don't know is these
asymptomatic individuals when they're in
with
large numbers of people who are not
vaccinated do they have the ability of
spreading
at all and that's what we're learning
over time and until we have that data
larger gatherings are going to be
restricted travel is going to be
restricted but i think over the next
several weeks again we'll have that data
and you're going to see some more
allowances given
on a similar subject for people who are
fully vaccinated and more and more
americans are coming into that category
why is it important for them to continue
to socially distance in public and wear
their masks
again for that exact same reason is that
we don't know their ability of
asymptomatic spread to people who are
not vaccinated
we're learning it we think it's much
much lower obviously than if you hadn't
been vaccinated but it's probably not
zero
and so we need to get some more data
from the united kingdom from israel
where there are large pockets of the
population that have been vaccinated
and where they can be studied and in the
next several weeks we're going to get
more there you know so this is the
beginning
this is the beginning of the next
several months of slowly enabling more
privileges to get back to a new normal
where are you on the subject of a
vaccine passport as it's called some
kind of documentation
allowing people to move more freely do
you think that's a good idea
a hundred percent is that that's going
to have to happen
states are going to say i don't want an
unvaccinated person coming into my state
because
there are people who won't respond to
the vaccine and i don't want to put them
at risk
restaurants may say we want have
everybody vaccinated so we can have
people without masks in the restaurants
so yes i think that's going to be the
new normal if you want to travel if you
want to go out to a public place
you will have to show that you have
immunity yeah and if you're not
vaccinated yet take a look at these
benefits and they're only the beginning
they're going to increase dr david agus
thank you very much